chapter 8 outside icon pitches to some
peasant logic yeah yes I don't know the
combination
luckily there's a nightclub but I can
get someone drunk yeah yeah yeah
touching my body yeah wait a kms Cotter
thank you I can't I press this button
you shut your [ __ ] mouth Yuri [ __ ]
what can I do actually
I just saw the sign I don't even know
what I'm doing here of course you do cuz
you where this place was jumping and you
heard right my man we got grooves so bad
we make studio 54 look like offseason
fat King it's kind of empty in here yeah
no I know man we literally just open
like five minutes ago
they come in they all come don't you
work I wish I was name tape it honey
no [ __ ] no it could use a beer I guess
a beer in here you embarrassing me here
but I got university degrees in Nick
sauna me and mixology okay what's it
they're just a bear place a dollar it's
yeah I think a lobby that batch corpse
is that him
Fox's capable doing here
shot Pam hang on another corner I got 50
cents
hey Chum mark into that corner in here
the freakin hole in the ground
you got it buddy let's go
you never touch our leg and just sing
sweet Jesus hallelujah God more coins if
Chase is shut Oh added some Quinta thing
[ __ ] yeah oh that ain't in there
another cable
okay I got my dollar
hey that's cable look at that ranch sir
would you kindly step away from there
yes Stefan betch the ranch here
I only had like a mirror I could
probably get the disco ball
oh I can buy that beer now then get the
welder man good man good man
I got your beer
I got your own you're my batch just made
that Bo's then I just need that Bo's I
changed my mind
for the money Canberra
whoa hold your horses chief oh can I
take that disco ball now are you making
this
oh [ __ ] get it get it
get it thing now you could just give me
that check
whoa mark check mark
che palle tank that could just keep on
drinking it but [ __ ] it
mmm-hmm I don't know what to point out
when I do
ballsy about it wait okay
hey bro you near this
pay phone
he have an account screwdrive can i my
white [ __ ]
that's loose [ __ ] now
okay a chapter
you know this way together
missiles up in here I don't want to
crawl through because why you see it
dead
maybe drain the water here
hesitate camel
nope I drained the water from up there
from inside the club or the club's like
filled water
yeah okay he's a gun
buck
somebody's gonna rob that dude it's kind
of [ __ ] up
I think what's gonna arrest that guy hi
yeah [ __ ] stick them up
you know laughing out there I'm just
having a good old time look in America
just shoot that box
here we go
madman strikes again
two [ __ ] at
hello is anyone in here try the muzzle
split guess this gun was a bit too rusty
after all that's a shame
you know there's
can I not go through here again
let's cut this [ __ ]
he's probably pissed he's trying to kill
[ __ ] get my cable get that wrench
how's easy didn't even need to use the
wrench [ __ ] on this jet hatch
nuts and that's just saying